trickshot artists Garrett Hilbert Cody
Jones
Tyler Tony and twins Kobe and Cory
cotton make up a little group known as
dude perfect and they have one of the
biggest channels on YouTube dude perfect
it's now so big that their channel now
has even more subscribers than the NFL
NBA MLB and NHL combined they have their
own television show on CMT and they're
sponsored by a wide range of major
companies and they even have their own
crazy trickshot Factory in Frisco Texas
they've transformed themselves into one
of the most successful brands to come
from YouTube but it all started as five
college roommates hanging out in their
backyard
Tyler Toni the group specifically calls
him their leader
Tyler Toni is the dude on camera making
the majority of the group's trickshots
dating back to the very first video born
in Plano Texas on March 24 1989 Toni did
most of his growing up in nearby prosper
Texas and spent much of his time in
church ever since I can remember I grew
up in the church my earliest memories
are being in church every Sunday at
youth every Wednesday Alana's every
Monday night Toni also spent a lot of
time on youth athletics and his efforts
paid off
he stands five foot nine but played
quarterback developing a passing acumen
that helps him make many tricks shots
today after high school
Toni attended Texas A&M and started
looking for some other Christian guys to
develop a friendship with Toni credits
that as the true start of dude perfect
purity new Garrett hilbert from the high
school basketball team and they soon met
the twins and Cody Jones in 2009 they
all moved into a house together and put
a basketball hoop in the backyard that's
when they began betting sandwiches on
whether or not one of them could sink
unusual basketball shots in their
backyard hoop after some success they
decided to shoot a video over two
afternoons this ended up becoming their
first youtube video backyard edition
within a week it had over 100
thousand views soon after Good Morning
America called for an interview Tony and
dude perfect were on their way to
internet superstardom and Beyond along
the way Tony graduated from college with
a degree in Wildlife and Fisheries got a
real job for a while a married Bethany
Briscoe an elementary school teacher in
2011 Garrett Hilbert the purple hoser as
he's known defense was born in Texas
on May 13 1987 his dad's job moved him
to California during his early childhood
and at some point he found his way back
to prosper Texas before high school
because that's where he met Tyler Tony
on the basketball team just like Tony
Hilbert was brought up in a devout
Christian family but didn't really
understand what it met until sixth grade
I never really understood what going to
church meant you know I you know tried
to pay attention but pretty much ended
up scribbling on the sermon notes just
drawing throughout all that Christ was
just slowly telling me that about him
and what he did for me
Hilbert went to Texas A&M as an
architecture major remained close with
his high school teammate Tony and found
his way into the college house that
brought them all together he claims to
be the one that initially bet Tony that
he couldn't make a particular trickshot
I bet him that he would make it he
obviously made it my bottom lankan the
rest is history
he'll bit married in 2011 and he and his
wife have the baby boy together named
Owen Coby and Cory cotton Coby is known
as twin one because he's one minute
older than Cory aka 22 born on July 17
1987 they grew up in Woodlands Texas
playing basketball tennis dodgeball and
ran cross-country my dad was actually a
pastor and I know some people have mixed
feelings about pastors kids but for me
my parents were never pushy when it
comes to Christianity and they wanted me
to make a decision on my own whether I
actually believed it they both went to
Texas A&M as communications majors and
kept seeing Tony and Hilbert at various
Bible study groups on campus once the
four bonded over sports and faith it was
inevitable
that all move in together not only are
they the marketing geniuses in the group
they also seem to be the technical guys
being the point people for the group's
mobile game website and video editing
after they graduated from college they
went to work for their father's Church
in Austin before dude perfect really
took off during that period Cory wrote a
book about the group called go big make
your shot count in the connected world
Cody Jones born in Plano Texas on
October 9 1987 Jones grew up going to
church every Sunday with his family like
the other dudes in high school he played
for the school's basketball team before
attending Texas A&M to study finance and
real estate but for a time Cody Jones
focused more on basketball and girls
than on religion like any other teenager
as I went into high school man the the
things of this world kind of captivated
me once Jones got back on the straight
and narrow he met the cotton twins
whilst playing basketball at the
University rec center and they asked if
he wanted to be the fifth roommate in
the house after graduating from school
Jones married his wife Allison and
worked in commercial real estate until
their viral videos became a full-time
gig and the rest as they say is history
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which YouTube
celebs you'd like to hear more about